single most important thing that we
could overcome would be undo the damage
Reagan did to the media by abolishing
the Fairness Doctrine and by abolishing
the regulation of the Federal
Communication Commission that prevented
people from an op of people like Rupert
Murdoch from monopolizing many many
media outlets so that you know CNN Time
Warner large percentage owned by the
Mormons you know the ABC you know Disney
CBS Viacom few Giants own all the media
and then they just make it a propaganda
tool and you know the mussolini defined
fascism as the union of the corporations
and the government and the government
allowing corporations to gain control of
the information media the media should
be the vehicle of Education and
re-education of the population of in a
free country and they should be where
people see the misdoings of the people
they learn what the inefficiency of this
and that take they realized that this
and the other kind of thing should
happen and when media is presenting the
propaganda rather than to information it
then puts people into a state of defeat
and so the most important thing would be
to open up the door open up our eyes and
Rick we restore the sources of free
information